Russ's on twitter at dave ramsey dave
understand wealth inequality is it at
record levels is this a problem for our
country no wealth will never be equal
it's not even equal in communism and you
will never you will always have wealth
inequality because you have people that
work more than others you have some
people that are smarter than others some
people that are prettier than others
some people that have more discipline
than others some people have better
timing than others and so it wealth
should be unequal it should be unequal
if you work 80 hours a week you ought to
make more and have more than somebody
that works two hours a week and lives in
their mother's basement whining about
wealth inequality so wealth it should be
unequal it would be unfair for wealth
and them to not be unequal now are there
some anomalies along this discussion
that are bizarre sure there are but you
know if I sell two million books should
I should I make more money or less money
than my buddy Brad Thor who sold 10
million fiction writers I hate them they
sell so many books it's ridiculous I
mean Brad sells 10 million books I
worked my butt off I sell 2 million so
should he get more than I've got yes he
should
he sold five times more books than I
thought yes so no it's it's you know now
again that there are some bizarre stuff
there's stuff like you know the janitor
makes one onesie into what the CEO of
the major huge fortune 500 company makes
I get all of those comparisons and I get
that that makes you your little self
whine and you get all upset about things
being fair but Fair has a ferris wheel
that's what fairy is Bears wear cotton
candy is that's what fair is you're not
gonna find fair honey it's not coming
and so the best thing you can do is to
get really focused on you and what you
can do to produce wealth for you and
your family we are finding we're in the
middle of a millionaire study I
mentioned this yesterday and here's the
bombshell we heard four years through
the old millionaire next door study that
78% of millionaires were
first-generation rich in our study of
almost seven thousand millionaires
already so far it's 96 percent our first
generation rich almost all of them so
inherited money doesn't make people rich
work does and smarts does and business
acumen does and getting a degree in
marketing instead of getting a degree in
German polka history you know you just
have to think out there people so I mean
if you get a degree in German polka
history you shouldn't make as much as
somebody gets a marketing degree because
there's not as much demand for German
polka history there's just not a lot of
demand for it there's a lot of demand
for marketing and so you got to figure
out I mean this is how life works
so yeah wealth will all I hope wealth is
always unequal now I I don't want
anybody to be hurt and I'm not trying to
get anybody on the bottom end of the
rung to be stuck there but in America
today truthfully most people are stuck
because they're stuck between their two
ears they're not stuck for any other
reason one-third of the millionaire's
we're studying or from lower-class
families lower and middle lower working
class families one-third of the
millionaires you believe that ya care if
you believe it or not is the truth we
have the most consummate study and I'm
just now beginning to get through the
data on and it's just inspiring and the
point is anybody can do it but not
everybody will do it and so everybody
shouldn't be equal thank God we're not
communists
thank you thank you God that we're not
communist this is the Dave Ramsey show